the democrats cannot stay on message
they don't get it eric swalwell just
proved this you remember eric swalwell
he is best known for his incontinence on
a cnn camera and for dropping out very
very early of the 2020 presidential
primary and for sleeping with a chinese
spy eric swalwell tweeted out yesterday
in an attempt to exploit the buffalo
massacre that the shooting that took
place over the weekend he wanted to
exploit it for his own political
purposes and so he tweeted out quote
my four-year-old just facetimed to ask
what i'm doing to help the people of
buffalo and why did the bad man do this
absolutely gutting this cannot be
his normal i guess he is there's a typo
there it's time to ban assault weapons
hashtag and gun violence
never mind for a second that swalwell is
using
such a
deeply insincere and ridiculous
tweet format people make fun of this
they said my three-year-old just called
me and he asked me daddy how do we how
do we reconcile deontological and
consequentialist ethics and i said son
son i don't know and then everyone in
the tsa line applauded my 18 month old
baby just texted me and he said uh daddy
uh how do we how do we resolve the
riemann hypothesis and i said i don't
know sunny
let let me let me go visit your
princeton math class and then everyone
at harvard applaud it and this is the
kind of format that everyone makes fun
of it's become a meme and eric swalwell
sent this out sincerely as though his
four-year-old was was facetiming him and
asking him about these things but but
even worse for swalwell
he's not on message he doesn't realize
that while of course the democrats are
exploiting the mass shooting to advance
their own political agenda they're not
doing it on gun control right now
the way that the democrats are
exploiting the the tragedy is to try to
incite a race war the way that the
democrats are currently
exploiting the tragedy is to try to get
tucker carlson fired that's what they're
they are going to get to gun control
that is going to happen but they're not
on it yet and so swalwell he's not even
on on the the right moment of of the
messaging of the propaganda of the way
that the democrats are exploiting this
tragedy really embarrassing though not
surprising eric swalwell is not ready
for prime time
megyn kelly our friend megan kelly
just threw her hands in the air she was
so furious at the way that the democrats
had been exploiting the strategy she
asked a simple question she said hey
before all the political maneuvering
can we just take a couple minutes to
mourn
some in the media
have been quick to point fingers and
even place
on our friend and very popular fox news
host tucker carlson it's outrageous it's
wrong both factually and morally
why do we have to go to that place
immediately on these stories why can't
we spend two minutes mourning the people
who are dead and trying to understand
that we have insane people in this
country we have lunatics
it's a huge country
we're not going to be able to get rid of
them all
it infuriates me people have to inject
their politics into everything and this
guy had a racist manifesto there's no
question that doesn't make it tucker
carl's fault just stop it
just stop it
megan is so good at these sorts of
stories telling these stories especially
with with this kind of
level of tragedy to it and really
conveying
what happened and who these people were
and she's really really good at that
but in answer to her question can't we
take two minutes to no we can't
we can't the the democrats will not let
us do that
the reason that we can't just take two
minutes to to mourn before this becomes
political is because the only reason
that the media are having us talk about
this at all
is to attack conservatives that's the
whole point
megyn kelly says can't we just mourn for
two minutes before we politicize
a tragedy like the shooting in buffalo
the answer is no because
if
if the shooting in buffalo
did not fit the predetermined democrat
narrative if the shooting in buffalo did
not serve to advance the democrat
political agenda we just would not be
talking about it maybe you would have
heard about it it was a really horrific
attack maybe you would have heard about
it for a day or two but it would have
just disappeared we wouldn't still be
taught it would be like the waukesha
killing where a
black racist drove his car into a crowd
and killed a lot of white people during
a christmas parade not that long ago
just just what at the end of november
and you would have heard about it for a
day or two and it would have just
disappeared because it wouldn't have
served to advance
the media's and the political
establishment's agenda
it would have been like the new york
city subway shooting
the new york city subway shooting was a
black racist who went down there and
shot lots and lots of people over 20
people i think were injured in that
shooting
but it was a news story for a day or two
and then it just disappeared had the
shooter been white it would have been a
news story
until today it would have been a new
story for six months same goes for
waukesha
so in in just a very technical answer to
megan's question no you won't get the
two minutes to mourn
we wouldn't we wouldn't be talking about
it
the whole it's sick it's sick and it's
really sad that this is the way the
media work
but
the only reason
that this is in the news
it's not the human tragedy
it's not the the sorrow that everyone
feels for the the victims families and
for the victims themselves it's not the
anger that people feel at the shooter
it is solely to be used as a cudgel to
attack the political opponents of the
media and of the political class i'm
glad you like that clip now smash and
like and ring and click and hit the
whatever you know subscribe get the
notifications also head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play go
get the michael knowles show five-star
review maybe leave a 10 star review if
you don't mind we'll see you next time
[Music]